okay the big news a couple of days ago
was that North Korea suspended its tests
of nuclear weapons capabilities and of
course immediately Donald Trump's
flunkies touted it as this just major
major accomplishment of trumps
administration and of his testicular
fortitude and they tried to say Kim
jong-un is finally just accepting the
reality that he must stop nuclear
testing because of the strength of Trump
and the fear of a bloody nose attack or
who knows what and it was touted as a
big win in the geopolitical battle of
ideas or actions I don't know except
that we've now learned that North
Korea's nuclear testing location
actually collapsed right after five
nuclear blasts and this puts a
completely different spin on Kim Jong
Un's announcement that nuclear testing
is stopping which might not be because
of Kim jong-un just being very very
afraid of Donald Trump or because of
anything that Trump did but rather
because their nuclear testing location
broke not because of geopolitical
pressure and these nuclear tests have
been taking place on a mountain called
Mount man tap I hope I'm pronouncing
that correctly and a recent test that
sort of went wrong reportedly tore open
a hole in the mountain and a part of the
mountain collapsed on itself so first is
the political implication right what was
being touted by Trump is a victory for
his politics may have been actually a
self-inflicted wound by North Korea but
there's actually real humanitarian
concerns here there's radiation concerns
the possibility of major fallout leaks
the possibility of radioactive dust
escaping through holes or cracks in the
mountain and then politically there's
also another element here which is that
The Wall Street Journal is reporting
that Kim jong-un is not actually even
saying he's going to stop the
development of nuclear weapons he would
be stopping these specific tests which
is a very different scenario than the
one that the Trump administration touted
which is the entire program looking to
develop nuclear weapon capabilities is
being stopped so the big picture is that
it's not surprising that this ultimately
went bad for North Korea doing
land-based nuke test is quite risky I
think most of us can understand
the most likely scenario is that North
Korea's announcement about nuclear
development number one is not a signal
that they're going to stop all
development of nuclear weapons
altogether just that they're not going
to do testing at this particular site
and number two they are setting up two
most likely at this upcoming summit with
South Korea ask for completely not
viable things or concessions from South
Korea and also to agree to completely
unenforceable verbiage this is how North
Korea works they will agree to
provisions in principle that are very
very difficult to enforce but also say
things like we are ready to stop all
nuclear research as soon as the Korean
Peninsula is denuclearize completely
which to them means that all American
troops leave South Korea because
American troops represent the United
States which is of course a nuclear
power it's just not gonna happen
right and this is how things have worked
for a long time it's not for better or
worse it just is if you look at the 1992
agreement on reconciliation between
North and South Korea if you look at the
joint declaration of the nuke
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
we've had a number of not just
discussions but extensible agreements
before and yet we still are where we are
today so what's being presented here as
a major change in North Korean
government attitudes is actually pretty
similar to what we've seen for decades
from various North Korean leaders so
what we have to do here is not just wait
and see what comes out of the meeting
but wait and see what actions come out
of whatever agreement is made at the
meeting and in the years that follow and
I would not be at all surprised I'm
optimistic I would love to see actual
changes in North Korea I would not be
surprised if we basically see more of
the same the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40 percent discount off
of your membership